Cheyenne is single why because she wants  the best man possible so what she's  saying isn't true I'm sure there are  plenty of men that love her would sing  for her but she hasn't married them why  she wants the best man possible not the  man that's gonna love him the more a man  simps for her the more she's gonna be  repressed I feel like Cheyenne really  didn't like him I think Cheyenne is  doing the usual thing that women do  which is being not self-aware not  intellectually honest there's a reason  why she's still single it's because  she's looking for the best man and I  hope she finds it and I hope Myron gets  as many wives as he deserves